(audience applauding)
With summer right around the corner,
we could all use a little fun,
and nothing, scream fun, nothing screams fun like toys,
and here with some of the hottest toys on the market
this summer is senior editor, and the toy,
excuse me, my God, Leo, help me.
It is okay, you know what?
Do you want me to read it for you?
Yes, Leo, thank you.
(audience laughs)
Here with some of the hottest toys on the market
this summer is senior editor of "The Toy Insider,"
Maddie Michalik, how are you?
I'm great, how are you?
(audience cheers and claps)
Nice to see again.
Thank you, it's great to be back!
(audience laughing)
No, no, it's not my show!
It's not my show!
Well, who to help me review than my dear,
dear, dear friend, the one and only Leo Kelly,
the Shirley Temple King?
(audience cheering and applauding)
Thank you so much for having me on again,
and thank you for bringing all these toys.
Now, Maddie Michalik-
No problem.
Thank you so much for being here today.
I mean, what's it like to be in your job?
I have the best job ever,
playing with the coolest toys of the year.
All right, Maddie, what toy do we have first?
Yeah, we are ready to play, right?
So, let's start off with "KanJam."
You guys go over to that can over there,
and grab the two discs over here.
So, this is, you go on the other side with Leo.
Oh, okay.
It looks like a pancake.
So, this is super fun.
Looks like a Frisbee.
Flying disc game that the whole family can play.
So, you guys are gonna try to get the Frisbee
over right here, and I'm gonna try to smack it in.
Oh.
And if you really wanna
try to get an ultimate victory,
you can get it right in this slot here.
I'm being completely honest with all you.
I am horrible throwing a Frisbee.
It all, it has mind of its own,
it's like, ooh, I'm a Frisbee.
Oh, you wanna go straight?
No, I'm gonna go this way.
Whee!
(audience laughs)
Yeah, well, let's see it, let's test it out,
let's see how crazy your Frisbee goes.
Let's hope.
Let's go!
Ooh!
See?
That was pretty good.
It wasn't bad.
(audience laughing)
It was not bad.
All right, Drew, let's see what you got.
You got this, Drew.
Ooh!
See?
You were close!
Leo, mine was way further out.
All right, "KanJam."
Leo, thoughts?
Thoughts, for me, it's a great outdoor party game,
and that's what I really, really love about it.
Plus, you can make like challenges,
and goals, and like trick shots.
You could be like, oh, can I make it from here?
Can I make it with my eyes closed from here?
It's really, really fun,
'cause there's different styles you can play it, right?
Okay, Maddie, what's next?
All right, so both of you take a seat
on either side of this treasure chest.
So, we're gonna go on an epic adventure
with the "Kinetic Sand Treasure Hunt."
Oh, this is my favorite.
Yeah, so you can bring the beach with you anywhere
with this Kinetic Sand compound, which feels just like sand,
but it will never dry out.
All right, let's-
So this treasure chest over here
is filled with a bunch of different surprises.
So, start digging through-
Oh, there's stuff in there?
Yeah.
Yeah!
And let's see what you can find.
I have a joke for you guys.
What did the pirate say when he turned 80?
Aye, matey, you know, like, "I'm 80?"
Oh!
Aye, matey.
Yes!
(audience laughs and claps)
Was that a good one?
That was a very good one.
Oh, I found something!
Oh!
Let's go!
Tag team.
Leo,
what do you call a eagle with no hair?
No clue!
A bald eagle!
Oh, oh!
(audience laughing)
That's good.
That's awesome.
All right, so, you can dig around for treasure.
Leo, thoughts?
I love this genre of toys, because you don't just open,
you're not just like, ohp, I opened it, ohp, it's done.
You really gotta absorb it, take your time.
Plus you can like reuse the Kinetic Sand, put it in a bag,
there's so many different things you could do with it.
And oh, you know what?
Let's show this.
You take this like pasta dough, ya flatten it.
Then you use this, it's a cookie cutter.
Leo, I love you.
How cool is that?
(audience applauding)
All right, Maddie, what's next?
Yeah, we gotta keep on moving, all right.
Ah!
Come on, join me over here.
So, this is the giant "Giraffe Ring Sprinkler,"
and it is eight feet tall.
This is like three of Leo Kelly, right?
Like, yeah, three Leos!
I know, it, look, I mean, it's big to me,
I can't even imagine.
It's so easy to use,
you just hook it up to a hose,
and water will start flying out of its nose, but-
So you just put a hose.
Yes, but you can also play without water,
which is still super fun.
So, wanna try to shoot some baskets?
Cool, yeah.
In the middle of the ring?
Let's go, guys!
(audience cheers and claps)
Whoo!
Oh!
Go, Leo!
Wait, Drew.
Nothing.
Let's do a tag team poop.
Tag team poop!
Mwah!
(audience cheering)
We did it!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Nothing but net, Leo.
Both of you did amazing.
(upbeat rock music)
♪ Oh, oh ♪